we're going to begin with the news and
the news is not good out of turkey a
terrible situation unfolding a turkey
and Syria now after two massive
earthquakes entire neighborhoods appear
to be leveled as rescue workers continue
to pull people from the rubble including
children however the death toll is
climbing and now above 5 000 and cold
weather is complicating survival for
those forced to sleep outside Chris
livesay has made his way to Turkey for
us and a warning this is a tragedy and
the footage of what you're about to see
is very disturbing Chris good morning
Good morning Tony well some of those
lucky enough to escape death have been
brought here to this hospital but
meanwhile countless more remain missing
or trapped as Rescuers battle both the
cold and the clock to save them
for all the suffering on the surface
there's Untold more beneath it
a trapped woman's faint blood curdling
scream
might be the only thing to escape
they're calling out for help but how can
we nobody has come look around look
when help finally arrives it can be too
late it's a battle against both time and
the elements as temperatures plummet
along with the chances of survival with
every passing breath the region
bordering Syria is the epicenter of both
the earthquake and a refugee crisis
where Millions have escaped the
destruction of War only to find
destruction Again by another name
the white helmets volunteer Rescuers
seasoned by the war in Syria
pry out young Ahmed a displaced child
and bring him to safety
my darling they say to comfort him come
on my darling
hospitals in Syria now overflowing were
already stretched by a cholera outbreak
as dozens of powerful aftershocks Rock
the ground beneath their feet
it's now a question of how far they can
stretch before they snap
the World Health Organization says as
many as 23 million people may have been
affected by the earthquake among those
coming to help them are Rescuers from
the United States so First Responders
firefighters Medics coming from Los
Angeles coming from Virginia even
bringing their rescue dogs but just
getting here over mangled roads covered
in ice and snow could prove the
difference between life and death Gail
they're working so hard Chris let's say
thank you those pictures are very hard
to watch when you can see the pain and
the agony and it's always the children
that get to me Agony is the word for it
oh yeah that's very tough hopefully
there will be survivors today hopefully